-My first guest is a
very talented actor.
He stars in
"Space Jam: A New Legacy,"
which hits theaters and
HBO Max this Friday.
Please welcome Don Cheadle!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what I'm talking about.
Oh, that's what
I'm talking about!
That's -- that's a good man.
Come on, buddy.
Welcome back.
It's so good to see you.
Thank you so much
for doing our show.
And I just want to start off by
saying congratulations
on getting nominated for
an Emmy, buddy.
Yesterday --
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
"Falcon and the Winter Soldier."
It only took you
five minutes of screen time,
and you got nominated
for an Emmy.
That's how good you are.
That's how real it is.
-Well, it's like that
concentrated orange juice.
You know,
you just take a tablespoon
and put it in water
and stir it around.
and it's Cheadle, you know.
-Can you tell us anything about
"Armor Wars" or --
'Cause that's coming out soon.
I know you can't, but can you?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, we just are actually
trying to figure out
what it's going to be,
how to figure out a way to,
you know, put you in it,
which I know
you keep texting me about.
-Yeah, I just would
love to be --
I just want to be
in that universe.
-Yeah, we'll figure it out.
Stop texting me, please.
-Just throw me
a little bone, something.
That's all I'm asking for.
You know, Don, I follow you on
all the socials and I love you.
You're a good follow,
by the way.
Don Cheadle,
if you want to -- Yeah.
So, in your Twitter bio,
you're @doncheadle,
but your name above that
you can change.
You changed it to...
So "Don't Ask Me Any Google
Questions Cheadle."
What is a --
Who asks you Google questions?
-Everybody.
A lot of people on Twitter
like to ask me Google questions,
like, you know, "Wow,
that movie that you're in --
when does it come out?"
I'm like, "You can
find that out on Google."
-Don't make me Google, yeah.
-Please don't make me Google.
-You got to come
right to the source.
They're gonna come
right to Don Cheadle
and be like,
"When does it come out?"
-Yeah. Yeah. Well, yeah.
-I love that you do that
and I love that you have
a good sense of humor
about all of it.
I will tell you, though,
"No Sudden Move,"
which is out right now on
HBO Max, streaming --
if you haven't seen that,
watch Don Cheadle.
It's a masterstroke.
That's what I'm talking about.
That's my man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Knows how to do it.
You crushed it.
-Thank you man.
-You crushed it.
And I also wanted to say I love
your mustache in that, as well.
You rock a good mustache.
-Yeah, appreciate that.
-Yeah.
-I've been growing
facial hair for, you know,
on and off for since I was 18,
so I feel like I finally hit
the sweet spot, you know?
-I want to talk about
"Space Jam: A New Legacy."
It's so exciting.
You -- I know you're a
big basketball fan.
To be in
"Space Jam: A New Legacy,"
what was that like
when you even got the call?
Did LeBron call you?
-No, LeBron didn't
call me personally.
-Oh.
-But, you know,
we've since, like, you know,
developed a great friendship.
And it's really nice to
have a movie do something
beyond just be, you know,
something that you're in.
We make these
satellite families,
and, often, you know,
we don't see these people again.
But we've kept in touch
pretty consistently,
and that's been cool.
And we just saw the movie,
and it's really fun.
And I think people
are going to dig it a lot.
It was a very cool experience.
You know,
it's what you would imagine
being in that fantastical world
with all those
animated characters,
and then you look over
and there's King James.
So it was kind of wild
but a lot of fun.
-Yeah. Your character is
Al G. Rhythm.
-Correct.
-Is it fair to say
he's a villain?
-You know, I think we're
throwing these words around --
villain, bad guy, misanthrope --
really liberally, you know?
I mean, I think he's a
misunderstood algorithm.
[ Laughter ]
-That is the first time that
anyone's ever called it that.
Yeah, he's a
misunderstood algorithm, yeah.
I guess so, yeah.
He doesn't consider himself
a villain.
-What villains do?
I mean, you've interviewed
some of them.
They rarely do.
-You've played basketball with
a bunch of famous people
over the years.
We've talked about some of them.
Who is surprisingly
a dirty player?
-I won't go
all the way to "dirty,"
but Adam Sandler
does like to throw his
girth around somewhat.
-What?! "Sandman"?
-Yeah.
Sandman likes to, like, get in
the low post and kind of --
you know, kind of
booty and back and bounce and
a little chicken wing.
You know.
-Yeah.
Chicken wing.
-He's old school.
He's old school.
He's old school, when that
kind of stuff wasn't illegal,
you know?
-Yeah.
What was playing with Obama
like? President Obama.
-That was a lot of fun.
It was great.
He was not on my team,
so I was playing against him,
which was also good, because I
really wanted to beat him.
But the person on my team
that was guarding him
didn't really
put it on him kind of like,
you know, you want someone to
in a basketball game.
I'm like, "Look,
I know he's the president
and I know the
Secret Service is right there
and will probably kill you
if you hurt him,
but you have to play hard.
He's a competitor.
He doesn't want you to
take it easy on him,
so guard this dude."
And he just kept
letting him go around him.
And he's like,
"He's the president."
I was like, "Look,
do you want me to take him?"
He's like, "No, I'll take him."
I'm like, "Then take him."
So, he went around him one time,
and I said, "Look, foul him."
And the president
looked at me and he said,
"Did you just say, 'Foul him'?"
And I said, "Yes.
Yes, Mr. President."
-I love that you called it out.
"Foul the president."
Yeah, come on, play ball.
-Foul this dude.
-Yeah, he would respect you
more if you played.
-Exactly.
-That's exactly right.
Well, I'm psyched about
"Space Jam: A New Legacy."
I'm so happy every time
you come on the show.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Don Cheadle
and LeBron James in
"Space Jam: A New Legacy,"
out this Friday.
Take a look.
-We're in the computer.
-We're in the computer?!
-Dad...
-You know I'm claustrophobic.
-How do we get out of here?
-Dad...
-Where's the elevators?
Hey, Siri, can you let us
out of here, please?
-Siri?
-Who's goes there?
-Aah!
-Who dares disturb the
great and powerful Al G.?
[ Laughs ]
Look at your faces.
You were terrified! "Aah!"
[ Laughs ] Priceless!
♪♪
See? Nothing to be afraid of.
-That's right --
nothing to be afraid of.
Don Cheadle, the one and only.
Don Cheadle,
"Space Jam: A New Legacy"
is in theaters and streaming on
HBO Max starting Friday.